bonjour david alors on le voit et on
l'entend également manifestement les
manifestants ont répondu présent à
l'appel des intersyndicales 51e jour de
protestation effectivement le cortège et
massif à la longueur du cortège est
assez impressionnante
tout comme le dispositif de sécurité mis
en place
encadrés par les forces de l'ordre
didier lallement le préfet de police
avait prévenu mettre en place tous les
moyens humains et matériels pour pouvoir
encadrer cette manifestation et surtout
pour éviter de nouvelles violences et et
des aides dégradation tous les corps de
métiers sont représentés dans le cortège
des avocats professeurs le personnel
hospitalier des cheminots évidemment
mais également et des élus venus
soutenir la cause des manifestants c'est
le cas de matt hill de panneaux députés
français soumise
je vous propose de l'écouter c'est
important qu'une part institutionnel de
la représentation nationale disent que
nous sommes avec celles et ceux qui
demandons le retrait de cette réforme
qui est une réforme injuste qui va faire
travailler tout le monde plus longtemps
pour moins d'argent
la motivation est toujours là là ce
matin j'étais sur trois piquets de grève
ratp il y avait des taux de grévistes
était très fort pour ce moment là donc
ils vont changer de stratégie parce
qu'après 51 jours sans salaire
ils vont changer stratégie mais il reste
déterminé à être contre la réforme
après c'est une bataille qui va encore
durer et moi je le dis solennellement à
emmanuel macron il faut de la
responsabilité on ne peut pas continuer
à gouverner contre l'avis du peuple en
république c'est le peuple qui doit être
souverain et on doit pas avoir un espèce
de monarques républicains qui continuent
à gouverner contre tout le monde et
envers tout le monde en 2005 une des
dernières batailles qu'on avait remporté
c'était contre le chrome contrat
première embauche
et il se trouve que la loi avait été
votée à l'assemblée nationale et que
c'est le président chirac à l'époque qui
au vu de la mobilisation populaire avait
refusé de promulguer la loi donc donc la
bataille elle va durer encore puisque ça
arrive mi février à l'assemblée
nationale puis en avril au sénat puis ça
doit encore revenir donc cette bataille
elle va durer encore longtemps et
j'espère qu'enfin
ce gouvernement va entendre raison et
arrêter d'utiliser la force contre les
manifestants parce qu'on a quand on a
plus que la force à utiliser c'est qu'on
a déjà perdu le fameux texte le projet
de loi pour la réforme des retraites
sera présenté aujourd'hui au conseil des
ministres et doit être examiné
mi février à l'assemblée nationale les
syndicats ne comptent pas lâcher et la
mobilisation va se poursuivre durant les
prochaines semaines un sondage qui est
sortie récemment de sondage et l'abc
français sur dix considèrent qu emmanuel
macron devrait retirer ce projet de loi
de réforme contre pour les retraites
le cortège lui en tout cas suit son
cours boulevard sébastopol pour se
rendre tranquillement vers la place de
la concorde point final de cette
manifestation qui est je vous le disais
massive